I spend most of my days in boardrooms
you have been in a number of those
boardrooms we got the biggest challenge
you think are in those boardrooms then
everybody's full of [ __ ] that people
don't make that people know but it's
true right like let's really like well
especially this is the man I [ __ ]
love it when it's like this so let's
let's let's talk about it for real right
the problem with boardrooms our people I
was so naive to corporate America I was
an auto my whole life I grew my family's
business then I was into startups
corporate America somebody makes a
decision in a boardroom or some of your
businesses that is completely predicated
on their bonus not what's best for the
product or completely predicated on how
they can politically grow within the
organization or how to make their boss
look good bad or indifferent so what
ends up happening is you sit in a
boardroom where people aren't aligned on
what's right me my dad bought every
single day for nine years building Wine
Library every day I fought with my dad
I'm proud to sit here and say that I
cried a hundred times cried but there's
one thing I think back to now that blows
my mind which is that my dad and I only
ever gave a [ __ ] about the logo it was
never about what my dad wanted it was
never about what I wanted it was never
about who made more money it was nothing
other than the [ __ ] local wine
library right that's not happening in
board rings corporate America people
don't give a [ __ ] about selling more
cereal or soda or [ __ ] and they're
thinking about other things and there's
seven agendas I mean I have a very tough
time with what's going on between
agencies and brands I don't think that
our agendas are aligned like you know I
think agencies do a terrible job back to
my naivete to you guys like I didn't run
an agency I think the reason we built a
really big company really fast as I
didn't know the rules I didn't know that
like you should charge for every hour
that you sneeze right like I didn't know
this [ __ ] I just want to do the best
work I just wanted to do what was right
I just wanted to sell [ __ ] go figure
fair enough yeah but you know at the
same time so it's real bye yeah no I
looked at I sit there with you I thought
the challenge that I faced more than
anything is what i see is so there's one
set of people in the boardroom no no
want you to say that there's one set of
people in the board room which is senior
leaders there is another set of people
in the boardroom which are more junior
marketers that enter into a system that
is actually built on not necessarily
making sure that they live up to their
potential so what makes me nervous and
you well then this let's talk about
school then yeah ferret out like if you
really want to know I think business
lunch on the real conspiracy yeah but I
think this is cool too I think you know
look one person people have student
loans raise your hand yeah [ __ ] blows
some horseshit or you know so we did we
did it we did a survey out of the top
100 business schools all of the
descriptions of classes only one percent
of those descriptions use the word
digital in it yes so let me tell you
something about business schools in
America you're looking at somebody right
now who failed who failed I I always
have the preface I tell all my friends I
was a bad student and I'm hanging out
with all these [ __ ] millionaires and
geniuses I think they think that I got
B's right unlike no [ __ ] I got
[ __ ] f's right so you're talking to
somebody up here right now who failed
all his classes who went to Mount Ida
college right cuz I got a postcard in
the mail 2nd semester of my senior year
and brought in my guidance counselor and
she's like [ __ ] it go and so all right
so meanwhile now I go and speak at all
these places right I go to Harvard and
University of Chicago and Michigan and
all these places and I always go and sit
and listen to the curriculum before I
speak because what I snipped out was
like holy [ __ ] it's abysmal abysmal
they're talking about [ __ ] that is all
about three years ago let alone now
that's crazy and I actually think we're
failing most of the people who are
entering in as a result of that but the
other thing I think so the challenge I
think you face is which I see you face
sometimes directly in that so many brand
marketers are afraid to actually take
your guidance and pull the trigger on
the things that you're suggesting of
course because nobody gets fired for
doing television or big knows that but
the bigger problem that is not that they
don't get fired they become obsolete in
25 years and they sit and say stagnant
and the exact same place in their career
so what I get frustrated about is that
they're not told that the way to
actually grow is to do things different
by the way there's a ton of people who
look the same there's very few people i
think i think i think the other thing
we have to realize it's not an
all-or-nothing game the thing that has
blown me away about corporate or these
organizations is that they don't have a
Navy SEALs unit right like the US
government is the biggest thing and we
have the biggest military and I always
use this equation right like we have a
big army television print you know we
have a big army scale right but to get
certain jobs done there's like 40 dudes
40 chicks right that make [ __ ] happen
the fact that these organizations have
not created allocation of dollars for
ninja units to go out and actually make
[ __ ] happen seems crazy to me because
it's a very small allocation of dollars
in the scheme of what they spend each
year and meanwhile I mean listen you
know this and if we're gonna get into
this like you have your very junior
brand managers controlling the money not
senior leadership which is fascinating
to me right I think that's a good thing
I just think that we have any artists /
scared yes there's good you know like
and then I sit in all these senior
meetings that are like well the brand
manners aren't doing their job like
[ __ ] you're [ __ ] not giving them
the permission and the funny thing is in
the end of the day like essentially
judge [ __ ] but he does say that by
the way when there and you're like what
he really means is that the appropriate
terminology sorry sir Oh anyway I you
know we're running out of time I I just
thought that it was interesting and I
also think so you talked about the big
data I walked by a panel and said big
data needs to be small data and I was
like really that's kind of the but I
thought it was interesting about the
repackaging so one last question yeah so
what do you think is and I'm again I'm
talking from the brand marketer sampling
what kind of think is the one if you
could tell them to go do one thing that
would help open up their perspective
what would it be [ __ ] man there's so
many um one thing one thing one focus
one thing that could open up the problem
for me with that answer is the to answer
that question and I'm as many of you
know I'm never sure to give a quick
answer is that I only care about
execution I only care about execution so
when I try to reverse-engineer what a
brand marketer needs to do
actually then go and execute it could be
going to a conference of being inspired
it could be going and working with a
start-up for a month to see how it
actually is but the reality is it's
almost like you know if I told them to
do one thing it be to go tell their
bosses what they actually feel because
the horse [ __ ] is what's really the
problem the fact that that's the
community it's it's like relationships
it's you know people don't communicate
enough right like we just don't
communicate enough like that there's
just too much horse [ __ ] there's too
much [ __ ] and then people are
crippled to go and execute and that's
the real thing that you see and the
reason I think that my company can
execute is that I have not been able to
convince my team that I'm not joking
that I want to give them 15 minutes at a
time and that they can say anything it's
been surprising to me that they haven't
taken me up on that it's been surprising
if they're still scared of me and that
makes me realize holy [ __ ]
infrastructure man like me right like
you see what I am right there's still
that intimidation based on layers how do
we create something that gets actual
authentic real dialogue going on because
everybody is crippled by [ __ ] rules
and tons of tradition that doesn't
actually matter in a 2014 world and
that's why barnes & noble and borders go
out of business that's why in the
consumer packaged goods brands you guys
are always trying to buy chobani and
redbull and vitamin water and you're
unable to do it yourselves because
there's just too much horse [ __ ] which
makes you slow and everything is
predicated on speed speed is the game
and if you can't execute fast you can't
win because by the time you execute on
your promise the world [ __ ] moved on
you all right ladies and gentlemen give
a big round of applause to carry